il y avait on est bref et sa j'adore on
ne dit pas mathieu on n'est pas fait
pour être monogame à balancier nations
n'ont
peut-être car c'est un humoriste bien
connu mais que j'adore at home si les
gars assez chine aurait assez chic ouais
black assez chic ferrari risi c'est mars
ici paris pour y signer actionnaires
fixe regarde le lit et dans l'émission
cliquer de mouloud achour que j'adore
pour dc sincère regardez ce qu'a déclaré
j'ai été infidèle pendant longtemps ça a
été compliqué pour moi pendant très
longtemps à ce niveau là et j'apprends
et je m'en sors bien comment on guérit
de l'infidélité on guérit pas céder
période il faut être honnête avec
soi-même et
trouver les personnes qui vont qui vont
comprendre au départ que c'est c'est
plus du haut à la personnalité c'est
aussi la façon dont on voit des femmes
aujourd'hui qui a évolué là où une femme
ne pouvait pas avant exister socialement
sans être dans un couple ou d'en haut
dans le mariage être polyamoureux ou
être attiré par plusieurs femmes pour
avoir besoin de plusieurs relations en
même temps c'est pas un souci je crois
pas à l'idée de la norme parce que de
façon naturelle on n'est pas fait pour
être monogame mais ça peut être une
preuve d'amour j'adore ce mec bas pardon
je pose une question très simple qui
pensent qu'on peut être fidèle toute sa
vie
et peut être qu'ils croient à la
ferraille à la fidélité est franchement
arrête
tu me demandes si on doit être amoureux
je sais pas moi là on peut être amoureux
toutes ces personnes que je connais
plein de gens qui sont accros était fini
c'est sûr que jamais vous êtes et jeux
comme
vous avez des conjoints et conjointes et
j'ai pas beaucoup dans la merde ouais si
je suis mais
je suis sûr que je vous pose la question
ici ici est ce que quelqu'un ici n'a
jamais était infidèle personne me répond
ah oui
[Applaudissements]
j'avais dit existe oui moi j'ai dans mon
entourage et parmi mes aïeux ce groupe
qui sont incroyablement fidèle et qu'est
ce que tu as à faire accoucher ma fille
maëlys et des coupes mais vraiment je
connais pas m animaux certaines espèces
sont monogames alors oui on a là où les
oiseaux les signes les cannois ouais mon
alma nous on est humain
mais il ya aussi je pense beaucoup de
couples qu'en fait qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix que d'être fidèle parce qu'en fait
ils passent c'est pas toujours facile de
trouver un partenaire quand le temps
passe quand on n'est pas toujours très à
tuer leurs gardes mais c'est vrai il ya
aussi des coupes qui en fait pourrait
potentiellement être infidèle mais tu ne
sont jamais oui ce que la vie mais c'est
sûr que c'est un vide dans une ferme à
122 to
remake qui sont infidèles parce qu'ils
sont trop sur la fidélité de leurs
femmes elle leur mettre des cornes tout
de suite j'aime autant vous dire qu'il
appliquerait plus mal décoré ce qui est
intéressant pour rebondir sur les
la déclaration de faris et plus en plus
de personnalités de people parlent de
leur fidélité ou pas c'est quelque chose
d'assez nouveau il ya encore quelques
temps il faisait très attention à ça et
yannick noah notamment dans le
documentaire qui lui est consacré sur
prime vidéo il a dit un truc assez
incroyable il a dit pour la première
fois de ma vie je suis célibataire je
m'endors seul je me réveille seul et il
dit vivre la plus belle période de sa
vie il est heureux d'être célibataire
parce qu'on avait jamais réussi à être
monogame justement comme disparue donc
c'est intéressant mais vous savez que
j'ai une petite astuce pour les gens qui
ont envie de tromper leur conjoint pape
renouvelle pas le faire mais un rêve de
lutter comme si c'était de la
culpabilité écoutez il faut le faire
dans son rêve d'embrasser les petites
idées d'évasion je réessaie d'ailleurs
rêver déjà rêvé que j'étais en coupé ou
je suis pas content on est en 2020 de 2
d arrêter de faire croire ce qu'on nous
faisait croire à nous petits catholique
à l'école c'est peu c'est coupable et
que c'est mal c'est une cdc mamadi le
temps que tu as trouvé quelqu'un avec
qui tu es sûr de ton quotidien de ton
projet de là où tu veux aller avec lui
le reste pardon cesser ces techniques
concernant l'armée moi quand je me suis
marié comme traître à dix jours et vous
fait léviter gêné faut voir donc
jamais trop plein
[Applaudissements]
m'a tuer la majorité des femmes parce
qu'il faut quand même distinguer la
sexualité des hommes et des femmes la
majorité des femmes sont fidèles et si
elles apprennent que leur mari les a
trompés je pense vraiment mais si
ça paraît 37% des femmes à 9% car neuf
mais tout ça c'est de ça sort d'où ses
sept succès non monsieur rabais d'été
des tic et
la ruse
1,3740 d'obsession ça sorte du site
extra conjugales rida êtes internet de
rencontres et en fait ils ont fait juste
la proportion d'hommes et de ses
divisions fidèle
des bas bien sûr par le passé j'ai été
marié en
mai valait présent non mais ouais moi
car dont je suis totalement d'accord
avec vous un pardon à temps par la suite
totalement faut arrêter de culpabiliser
les gens non menem l'amour on aime la
vie vous avez ma maison et de la
personne qui est en face de toi service
y est sous toit teuton d'homme ou ta
femme ont vraiment envie d'être fidèle
et que tu les trompes sans leur dire ça
laisse à peu les faire souffrir si le
tgv que l'irie
de la vie
avant tout le temps tandis que c'est toi
qu'est ce que tu as fait jeune nick est
la voisine
c'était sur place n'étaient pas bons il
peut et tu peux faire souffrir les
perdants quand même temps jean mi non
mais moi je trouve très peu mais je
kiffe malheureusement du coup j'ai une
réputation de mecs volage parce que je
supporte pas les deuxième vie je trouve
ça me fait paniquer de mettre son
téléphone à l'envers l'horreur si vibre
et c'est sans dire qui tu es bien son
nom c'est une nouvelle historique que
jamais au stade airbus à servel frères
quittez jamais ici mais en coupe et tu
verras c'est lui le deuxième jour offs 1
et mignonne et tout est magnifique bon
ben ce kit la suivant ce qui t'a
précédent il ya un jour et demi alors
évidemment c'est pas quitté